when Lord Godfrey's last worthy enemy
fell he was robbed of his grace and
driven from the lands between and his
tarnished Warriors went with him
according to cut content they left with
prayers of farewell affixed as small
Flags to their headbands for none
expected them to return theirs was the
Long March a dangerous Adventure during
which Godfrey's axe was broken in half
eventually they arrived at the bad lands
here in this frigid country Godfrey
finally devasted himself of kingship
becoming a simple Warrior once more
following the example of their Chieftain
the Brave Warriors of the bad lands
wielded axes of their own and shunned
excess adornment what little armor they
did wear served as symbols proof that
they had slaughtered countless foes so
it was that they lived waged war and
died but eventually Grace would call
back to these tarnish Champions it bid
them to rise from the dead and return to
the lands between so it is that the
Champion's Journey Begins